RICK: Hey, what do we have here?
It's a, uh, antique
hand-crank key cutter.
So, like, a Victorian era
James Bond would use this?
Right.
[laughter]
MAN: I came to the
pawn shop today
with an antique hand-crank
key cutter looking sell it.
Got the key cutter from,
uh, an estate sale.
I did some research online.
I wasn't able to really find
out what the key cutter was.
So that's what led me to
bring it to the pawn shop
to see if I could sell it
and find out more about it.
RICK: It's old.
It's cool.
And it's the duplicator.
MAN: Correct.
RICK: So do you know
anything about it?
Do you know who
manufactured it or anything?
MAN: I don't.
RICK: OK.
I don't think it's a key cutter.
Oh, OK.
RICK: Now, the reason I don't
think it's a key cutter--
MAN: Uh-huh.
RICK: --this is way too broad.
This would just grind
half the key away.
This was probably
designed to replicate
small parts of some kind.
- OK.
RICK: Or maybe even
small wood pieces.
What you do-- you put a little
piece of metal in here--
MAN: OK.
RICK: --smaller than the
penny, actually, or longer.
And you know, it's
plain and simple.
I mean, it's just, as you're
turning this crank grinding
into your piece of
metal right here,
you just follow that
piece right there.
MAN: So this would
be, like, the guide.
RICK: And that just guides you
over whatever you're doing.
It's a cool little machine tool.
You want to sell it?
MAN: I do.
OK.
And how much do you want for it?
Uh, I was looking for $1,000.
Well, have a nice day.
Even if it was a key cutter,
it wouldn't be worth that.
MAN: OK.
I mean, you can
get key cutters--
MAN: Sure.
--with electric motors
for a lot, lot less money.
But those aren't
antiques though.
Just because
something's antique
doesn't make it worth money.
I'm really old.
My kids, you know, don't think
I'm worth a lot of dimes.
It's not that rare and
it's not that desirable.
You could probably put it online
and you might get 20 bucks.
It's just not that special.
OK, yeah, I'll keep it.
I paid more than that for it.
So--
MAN: OK.
Well, thanks for coming in.
- All right.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
- It was cool though.
- Thank you.
- You can keep the penny.
[laughter]
MAN: I totally disagree.
I think it's a cool piece.
I think that there's definitely
a market out there for it.
And I think it's worth a
whole lot more than $20.